virginia police say that road rage may
have led to the murder of a muslim
teenager they say there is no reason to
believe that this was a hate crime at
this time nah bro Hassan and died on
Sunday the 17 year old teenager's body
was recovered from a pond she had
allegedly been beaten with a baseball
bat 22 year old Darwin Martinez Torres
is charged with her murder
chip Reid is in Fairfax Fairfax rather
Virginia chip good morning good morning
immigration officials say Torres is in
the country illegally and he could be
deported so far police say there's no
reason to believe he targeted naw bruh
because of her race or religion why he
killed my daughter for which reason
Mahmud Hassanein says he wants to know
why Darwyn Martinez Torres allegedly
killed his 17 year old daughter naw bruh
on Sunday you don't have no reason we
don't know this guy that's all he don't
know us in between Ramadan prayers at a
mosque in Sterling Virginia police say
as many as 15 teenagers including na
bruh walked and rode bikes to a nearby
McDonald's early Sunday morning on their
way back Torrez confronted the group in
his car an argument followed with a
member of Knob rus'
Torres drove his car over the curb and
the teens scattered we were just yelling
at him told him stop stop and then he
wouldn't stop then we decided to run
witnesses say that Torres caught up with
the group a short time later in a nearby
parking lot police say Torres then hit
naw bruh with a baseball bat and took
off with her in his car
police arrested Torres about two hours
later that evening investigators
recovered her body from a pond about two
miles from where she disappeared there
is nothing at this point to indicate
that this tragic case was a hate crime
it appears the suspect became so enraged
over this traffic argument that it
escalated into deadly violence
Joshua Salaam is chaplain at the mosque
nah bruh attended words are hard to to
express what the family is going through
what the community is going through
Hassanein said no parent should have to
face the death of a child my daughter
she died she's gone I
this happening to the other we were kids
because nobody feel what I feel now
police have not said with the argument
between Torrez and one of the teenagers
was about Torrez is being held without
bond there will be a vigil for nah bruh
this evening chip thanks